on the next Rick and Morty chicken coop
those are procedurally generated clouds
bet that river is a rainbow literally I
put real elbow grease into this place
you're supposed to put elbow grease into
your daughter gross Rick and Morty next
Sunday at 11:30 dad makes the toilet
look like r2d2 and it breaks the front
page of Reddit but I'm Charles Manson
because I gave you your own world
instead of an iPad so third season we
were gonna do an interdimensional cable
episode but then Morty found out the
mind-blower vault existed and instead of
doing it he had to look at all the mind
blowers so blame Morty if you wanted
that episode we are all a collection of
our experiences our memories we're
supposed to learn from them and we're
supposed to process them is Morty
eternally Morty because every time he
has an opportunity to become something
other than Morty
he or Rick keeps removing that potential
and also does more to keep making the
decision to remove bad things that
happen to him because he keep removing
them how many of these were just
horrible mistakes I've made I mean maybe
it stopped making so many if I let
myself learn from them the bigger
picture of this episode is that these
adventures are having a way more
profound and powerful effect and Morty
than we realized
and once again Rick took the easy way
out I think that it's interesting that
Rick knows that there are some things
that are so big that it's not that you
grow it just destroys you you simply
have to choose and so yeah maybe Rick is
a piece of [ __ ] for taking too many
memories out from Morty but he's keeping
the guy going to by taking this stuff
out I do it if there's nothing I can do
about a piece of information and all it
does is make me enjoy life less period
that's all then yeah why not knock it
out of there you do that with a tooth
man I have a lot of memories I wish I
could make go away
let go your baby let go of your baby
c'mere
put the money in the bag put the money
in the bag
[ __ ] it's the cops we call the cops so
sorry I'm so sorry I meant to shoot the
guard I meant to shoot the guard
everybody knew brick-and-mortar let's
break it down if you are just finding me
for the first time be sure to subscribe
to get everything they'll be giveaway
stuff at the end of the video too
the really important thing about this
episode is getting context for what
happened to most of the bets in the
multiverse when Rick went away on
adventures because you have to remember
that now this Rick has been to at least
two different dimensions since the show
started and on top of that he said he'd
been to over like 300 different versions
of Earth's moons meaning that he's
jumped to countless other dimensions so
c-137 rick's original Beth could be
somewhere way out there in the
multiverse we have no idea which one
this is other than it's the one that's
experiencing the divorce storyline 300
versions of Earth's moon including this
one and I've never seen signs of a
regular dude as you described him
hanging out you know I said we can only
do that a couple of times we're over
here so important thing to remember
c-137 Rick but not c-137 Beth but in the
way that things can be very similar
between realities I think we can assume
that this version of Beth is very close
to what happened with c-137 Beth but I
love the way he created a fruit peel and
to be sort of her daycare it's sort of
like an adventure time situation where
you have Finn and Jake running around
she had this great big place that Rick
imagined would be the ultimate fantasy
land for a little girl but obviously you
know the whole thing is that Beth is
like I really wanted my father to be
here but a lot of the comedy of the clip
here is just him trying to get her to
acknowledge how amazing it is
technologically like look at how much
work I had to do to turn a real-life
rainbow into a waterfall but the title
of the episode is the ABCs of Beth so
there might be some sort of literal
ABC's happening in this because it
sounds like this is where she received a
lot of her education but a lot of you
have also guessed that the title is a
play on the ABCs of death which is a
horror anthology series so there might
be some elements of that in this but
Morty's mind blowers was kind of the
anthology episode because it was
interdimensional cable without actually
being interdimensional cable so we'll
see what parodies they baked into this
but I do love the way they talk about
Morty's mine blowers in a
knowledge the idea that Morty's the way
he is because he keeps getting memories
removed meaning that he can't move
forward like he can't grow as a person
because he keeps getting all this
progress pulled out of him because some
of it just winds up being so harmful and
damaging to him one of my favorites and
it's an amazing example that they
included the clip is when he gets pulled
off at the level area it starts going
insane he starts having that orgasm
because apparently that's what precision
gives you they pull him off and he
almost immediately goes insane reality
is poison lambs to the cosmic slaughter
it was so hilarious but it's so crazy
how quickly he vacillates from one to
the other like orgasm to complete
insanity so of course there are memories
that he needs to have removed so Rick is
doing a good thing but like they said he
takes the easy way out because he
doesn't want to deal with a cocky Morty
and we know / Rick's explanation that a
cocky Morty is bad for everyone just
don't get too big for your loafers
Buster Brown a cocky Morty can lead to
some big problems could be a real bad
thing for everybody oh yeah how's that
explain when you're older but speeches
are for campaigning now is the time for
action that's who evil Morty is so they
haven't officially confirmed his
backstory yet but the theory evidence is
building for him just being a version of
Morty that still has all of those
memories inside his head but clearly not
enough memories to drive him insane like
getting pulled off of a level area here
but all the same if Morty can beat Rick
in a game and knows how to pronounce
words better than Rick does then evil
Morty can easily be smarter than a bunch
of Rick's but let me know what you think
about all this what'll happen is I'll
post a new Rick and Morty later this
week and then we have episode 9 on
Sunday we only have a couple episodes
left so start thinking about the bonus
videos that you want me to do during the
offseason but just like Game of Thrones
I will do Rick and Morty until season 4
gets here so we can talk more about
season 4 stuff as we get closer to the
end of the series they'll probably start
talking about it a little bit
but I think they're still working out
the business deals for Justin roiland
and Dan Harmon behind the scenes but
there will be a season for don't worry
about that they wouldn't have had jokes
like summer making fun of them for
infighting and taking so long to get
their work done no wonder you're so far
behind schedule if they didn't intend to
try and work faster to get season four
out but I do think it'll be next summer
before we see it like it'll probably be
next July around the time season 3
premieres so like the end of July so
just plan on that until we get more
information but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner Jorge Sanchez
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details you win what are the new
art books I'll announce a new winner
when I post new Rick and Morty you can
click here for my episode 8 video and
you can click here for brand new flash
season 4 thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome i'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]